I'm giving you guys these free samples
because the muffins are going bad Oh
compliments of this entire establishment
I don't know what this hand gesture
means outlandish comment about a
political candidate we all hate that I
just read about on Twitter confirmation
we we don't like him oh yeah no we are
definitely bonding over mutual dislike
repetition of slogan to test your
politics oh you know more Pete that
slogan baby huh I'm not well-informed
but on a few issues I am and I stand
with a different candidate than you guys
well I am also not well-informed but I
make up for it in passion I only read
Facebook statuses well isolating
negative things about their candidate
interrupting my personal identity right
now my candidate cares about my life our
lives a nice it's what rappers in public
and his handshakes are effortless
it's like watching my dad we all get
along if I just go back to dissing the
other side
I support the candidate you hate you
gave me muffins earlier so I'm gonna
pretend like I don't think you're a
monster using five syllable words to
demonstrate the fact that I'm actually
more informed than all of you yes our
front runner is not the best candidate
but I want my side to win so I'm just
gonna pretend that he's good
also I'm presenting way too much
information for you to refute at this
time I'm not listening I'm just waiting
time and concluding by saying that your
side is childish and whimsical
comparison to one of the most evil
dictators of all time getting eye
contact confirmation from my friends
referencing a u.s. politician from not
your time to justify my position on the
information I'm gonna go ahead and
remind you how that administration
affected my people
speaking overly cautiously so as to not
sound racist but realizing that I sound
racist okay I am going to say something
condescending that makes it sound like
your generation is overly emotional um
people are good society makes us bad
people are bad society makes history my
idealistic values and philosophy my
personal experience questions about how
this is gonna affect my taxes and the
people who have jobs like mine no I
don't that's not relevant to me because
I don't know anybody like you
that's literally everybody you don't
know anybody that stammering realizing
you can't relate to us because you come
from a generation of privilege that I
earned in the generation before you yeah
piggybacking off of that to shut you
down because you remind me of my dad
paraphrasing what you just said to make
you sound dumb look uh getting loud
hasn't worked so far so maybe I can get
the upper hand if I begin to yell I'm
frustrated with this no I'm frustrated
with the current system I'm mad because
we can't seem to get anything done we're
too busy yelling at each other this is
why I don't hip-hop of politics
hey man over here's your argument let me
tell you something I agree with you
something Ingrid and now she's meeting
you something racist one of these guys
have to be on our side oh you know what
something sexist I'm going to pretend to
look away